let's see if we can handle some slightly
more difficult a mean naming example so
if we look at this blue molecule right
here we always want to start off by
finding the longest carbon chain it
looks like it's this chain at the bottom
where we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 carbons so
it's going to be actin octan we don't
want to just call it octane because we
have these functional groups up here and
maybe one of them is going to take
higher priority than just this the fact
that this is an alkane and in fact one
of them will so let's look at them so
over here we have an amino group that
would make this molecule and a mean so
this is an amino group right here then
we have this benzene ring we have this
Venzon ring and when benzene is a
functional group we call it a phenyl
group we call it a phenyl group and
that's derived from I think I think it's
either the Greek or the Latin word for
light because benzene was first isolated
from from I guess the air around
lanterns or something so this is called
a phenyl group and then finally we have
this o H which would make this whole
thing in alcohol or we could call that a
hydroxy group so this right here is a
hydroxy group hi Drock see now this is
just something that you need to know
there's no way to kind of deduce it the
people who've decided how to name things
just decide that certain groups take
higher priority over others and out of
these three groups the hydroxy groups
the thing that's making this whole thing
in alcohol takes the highest priority so
this is what's going to define the
suffix so if we start numbering we want
to start numbering this chain closest to
the highest priority group so we'll
start numbering at this sense is 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 so we have a hydroxy group on
the 3rd 3 carbon so this is octan 3
octan 3 all if this was not a high
priority we would put a hydroxy in the
front but this is the highest priority
it's defining this as an alcohol octanol
but we put the 3 there to say it's on
the 3 carbon and then of course this
would be 5 phenol this right here is 5
phenol
five phenyl and this right here is eight
amino eight amino and amino comes before
phenyl in alphabetical order so this
whole molecule is going to be let me
write it over here it's going to be
eight amino eight amino five phenyl five
phenyl five phenyl octan three all and
we're done
octa knocked on three all three act on
three all and we're done so this is this
is an aromatic compound because if the
benzene ring
it's an amine because of the amino group
and it's an alcohol because of the
hydroxy group now let's look at this
molecule here in green and actually I've
forgot to draw a part of it this is
supposed to be a benzene ring so let me
make clear that is a benzene ring so
let's think about the different
functional groups here and it'll start
with the one that you've probably never
seen before this is a nitro group this
is a nitro group and it's highly
explosive maybe in a future video I'll
show you some nitroglycerin and some TNT
and as you know which are highly
explosive but they have nitro groups on
them so this right here is a nitro that
is a nitro group it takes very low
precedence in the whole scheme of things
so this will never almost never actually
never be the cause of naming the suffix
well then we just know that this is a
nitro group right here we of course have
a bromo group that we've seen many times
that is a bromo group and then we have
an amino group we have an amino group
right here so this is going to be let me
do this in a different color this is
definitely an a mean this is this is an
amino group right there an amino group
amino group and out of these three
groups the amino group is definitely at
the highest priority so you might be
tempted to name this one amino to three
bromo for nitro benzene but when a
benzene ring is attached to an amino
group this one also has one of those
special names and let me
just do it on the side right here so if
I just have a benzene ring if I have a
benzene ring if I have a benzene ring
attached to an amino group so that's an
NH 2 right there we call this molecule
right here and this is just the common
name for and it's something to put in
your linear toolkit
this is an ax lean and nailin and allene
so that will be the base name this whole
thing this whole thing right here this
whole thing we call aniline so let me
write it over here so this is an ax lean
and a lean and then we always want to
start numbering at the group that's
really defining the molecule so we
starting on bring here and you want to
go in the order where you're gonna bump
into something first so 1 2 3 4 so this
is going to be if we look at them and
bromo comes alphabetically before nitro
so it's going to be 3 bromo it's going
to be 3 bromo 3 bromo 4 nitro 4 nitro
running out of space aniline 3 bromo 4
nitro aniline and we are done